okay hi everyone thanks for staying so
late appreciate it uh i wouldn't do it
if i were you but it's uh
kidding so uh my name is adeerstein i'm
a vp product at a company called iguazio
we are doing envelopes and today i'm
going to talk about
envelopes and how customers are actually
implementing machine learning use cases
in production in their organization so
we're going to cover some of the
challenges and why they need to adopt
this
production first approach and also we're
going to cover some use cases around the
nlp
so i have a very interesting use cases
from a company called the s p global
that are doing nlp serving pipeline then
another use case is from samsung and
they're doing real-time accommodation
and another one is an envelopes use case
a generic envelopes use case from a
company called ecolab so we're going to
cover that
now as we all know customers are
building services business services
they're based on machine learning for
quite some time but one of the trends
that we're seeing in the industry is
that more and more use cases are
becoming more online and real time
oriented so we have things like fraud
prediction location based recommendation
predictive maintenance so we have use
cases across different industries
sometimes in healthcare as well and this
you know use case around online and real
time add another challenge to building a
machine learning operation
now
in in many cases what we are seeing is
that customers are starting to build a
model and they think that the main
challenge is actually to come up with
the best model the best accuracy but in
reality once you have the model and you
want to take the model to production
that's a lot of challenge and many
projects are actually fail because of
the operational aspect and why is it
it's because the research environment is
very different than production
environment if you think about it
as a data scientist uh you sit in your
you know room with your laptop you
usually take some kind of a small csv
file packet file and then you start you
know doing the feature engineering with
you know pandas dataframe and then once
you're happy with the feature
engineering that you're doing in your
notebook you're running some training
sometimes in in your laptop in in a
better case you may run it in your
testing cluster and eventually you come
to a point
where you have a model and now you need
to take it to production but the reality
is that in production it looks
completely different in production you
need to connect to different type of
data sources like databases streaming
engine object store you may need to take
data from different sources as well and
basically consolidate everything into
one now you also need to do a feature
engineering at scale so it's not only
about you know partners data frame but
you might you may need to take your raw
data and start doing the feature
engineering at scale using other tools
like spark or maybe dusk and that adds
another you know challenge another layer
of challenge to this equation now once
you have the feature engineering and you
want to train your model again it's not
only about training your model as a
one-time operation using your laptop now
you want to basically create a ci cd and
automate the pipeline that knows how to
take the data do the data preparation
running the training at scale basically
do the experiments tracking
figuring out which the best model that
you can
use and you want to do that at scale you
want to create an automated pipeline
that can actually do that so
once you have that model you need to
take that model into a deployment now in
many cases the deployment is not just a
model with an endpoint in many cases you
actually need to create a serving graph
that comprises of different steps so
it's not just the model and the rest api
you need to create the pre-processing
pipeline and i'm going to talk about it
later on and and that adds another
challenge to this uh you know the entire
story
now once the model in production you
also need to monitor those models so you
need to monitor more and to monitor the
model in in a way that you need to see
if this uh actually working in terms of
operational aspects you know latent
sierra and stuff like that but you also
need to check if the model is actually
working properly in terms of accuracy to
do model drift so that's basically a big
challenge and on top of that
you have different disciplines so you
have the data scientists they are
creating the model that's fine but once
you have the model you need to pass it
over to the data engineers because in
many cases they are taking the the
future engineering part and they are
starting to build the future engineering
part in in some cases they are using
different frameworks like spark and das
so they need to take your code and
convert it into something that can run
in a scalable manner in production and
then you have the devops and the
envelopes engineer they need to prepare
a kubernetes environment for the most
part and they need to prepare an
environment with automation and all that
kind of stuff so there are different
disciplines they're working with
different frameworks sometimes they have
different goals within the organization
so that's it's another challenge
then in general when you take the model
to production you need to take care of
things like security monitoring high
availability versioning
explainability all that kind of stuff
things that you don't do in your
development environment and to add to
that you have the feature engineering
now in many cases we're seeing that the
future engineering is actually the uh uh
the the most consuming in terms of time
so the future engineering part means
that you need to take the raw data start
doing uh analyzing which feature would
serve your model and this is a very long
exercise and we're going to talk about
that later on and last but not least the
model monitoring you need to make sure
that the model is actually running
properly
so
our approach is basically to uh to tell
our customers that they need to think
about production from day one so if you
think only about development and you
develop the model but then you hit the
wall of you know taking into production
it means that it's going to take you a
lot of time a lot of resources lots of
effort in order to actually deliver that
model into production but if you think
about how do i build the production from
day one how do i take you know all the
building blocks that they need in order
to take my uh development
the model that i've developed in the
development environment to production
that basically changed the paradigm okay
so think about production from day one
that that will make it much more easier
for you to streamline the development
effort all the way down to production
now what are the the production
components that we need we need
basically an envelopes platform that
allows you to take any kind of data so
it could be real time it could be batch
structure unstructured and then for the
most part if it goes as a structured
data you want to take it to some place
where you can actually do the future
engineering at scale so there is a
relatively new term in the industry for
the last you know one year two years
which is called feature store are you
guys familiar with feature store
yeah
all right give or take
so the feature store in a very high
level
it provides you two things one it's a
catalogue for pictures so especially
when large organization you have
different teams and each teams are
working on you know different type of
projects feature store basically allows
you to have a single pane of glass where
you can see all of your features you can
share features you have the metadata you
can basically reuse those features so as
a data scientist when you start a new
project you don't need to start from
scratch you can go to that catalog
figure out if there are
already existing features that you can
reuse and then you know basically you
have all the information in order to use
that feature
another thing that it provides you is
the ability to do the data
transformation at scale so you are
getting an sdk which is a stimulus decay
so you can do things like sliding window
aggregation one not encoding all the
transformation the typical
transformation that you need under the
hood that can that can trigger a very
robust engine like spark and dusk in
order to do this in future engineering
at scale
another point that is very important is
to run everything as a serverless
framework now why is it important to run
it as a serverless because serverless
provides a couple of things first of all
it's very efficient in terms of hardware
utilization so you can run more and more
containers you know small functions
leveraging the same hardware but in much
more efficient way
versus you know doing it
using a vm for example
it also provides you a seamless way to
develop your functions develop your code
and transfer those code into production
so you don't need to rewrite the code
again you don't need to deal with things
like security and logs and management
all that kind of stuff you're focusing
on the code and then there is a process
that basically takes this data and
convert it into serverless function that
can run in kubernetes kubernetes cluster
at scale so that's why serverless is
really important then the other thing
that you can do is obviously to run your
training process using serverless
approach so even if you're running you
know pandas at scale using dusk or whole
vod or maybe doing something with spark
you can still do that and it's also very
important to have an open environment so
you can run any kind of you know open
source that you want to leverage like xc
boost cycle and tensorflow whatever so
the openness is also very important and
then when it comes to deployment of your
model uh the serving as i mentioned
earlier in many cases it's not it's not
just the model and the rest endpoint uh
if you're talking about application you
need to do all kinds of pre-processing
so for instance with nlp you need to
take the pages you need to extract all
kinds of you know figures and sections
from that pipeline and the pipeline
becomes much more complex than that than
just you know putting a model with a
rest endpoint so building a graph that
comprises of different steps and do it
in a very scalable manner is very uh is
a key component to this architecture
now the other part is the model
monitoring so modern monitoring
obviously we all know it's very
important you need to monitor the
features that are running in production
and the prediction and all that kind of
stuff but what's important here in this
architecture is that this model
monitoring has a feedback loop to the
feature store now if you have the
features and the prediction
in production and then you have the
statistics of the features that you were
trained in the feature store then it
means that you can actually compare
between those two and identify if there
is a drift so those are the the key
components
that exist in in any type of
architecture for production and of
course if you're identifying that there
is a drift you can re-trigger you can
you know basically trigger an alert and
re-trigger this entire pipeline again
so when we think about the key
components for
a successful envelopes architecture we
have the feature store we can talk about
feature store for hours i mean there are
companies that are doing just you know
feature store but again in a very high
level it solved the the issue of future
engineering one of the the biggest
benefits of feature store is the fact
that you can do the transformation or
set the transformation logic once and
it's applicable for both the training
and the inference and that eliminates
eliminates the the data skewing that you
may have if you're working with
different
transformation sets so that's why
feature store is is really important
and the feedback loop between the
feature store and the model monitoring
is also very important in order to
identify if there is a data drift
the second item is this real-time
serving pipeline so as i mentioned
earlier this serving is not just about a
model with an endpoint in real world
application you need to create a
pipeline that comprises of different
steps those steps may have you know
relationship between each other and you
need to create this you know pipeline in
a way that can listen to events that are
coming in in an online manner and so on
and so forth so building a graph in your
serving pipeline and do it in in a very
easy way so you can actually do it in
your development environment and then
easily transform it into production is
also you know critical component here
and then the monitoring and the
retraining so once you have that set you
can basically identify if there is an
issue and if there is an issue you can
retrigger the entire you know pipeline
again and last but not least the
automation the ability to do ci cd for
machine learning so we're all familiar
with ci cd for you know the software
development world we want to do the same
thing for machine learning using git
using gen case and basically automate
this entire apartment so those are the
key components
now let's talk about some of the use
cases that we've seen
in the field
so we have a customer that is called the
s p global they are basically a global
information provider a pretty big
company doing a 3.6
billion revenue and their challenge is
to do nlp and scaling so their business
is all about data and they're getting
lots and lots of data they're analyzing
this data and out of this data they can
come up with their products and services
and the challenge is that they have more
and more data and they need to do it at
scale and they need to do it in more
like an online manner so
so let's dive into it so when it comes
to nlp uh just a little bit you know
context of what they're trying to do
obviously they're getting lots of you
know pdf sometimes it's just you know
images and they need to extract all
kinds of sections within that you know
page so it could be you know reference
of sections it could be all kinds of
formulas figures diagrams the auto name
description
all kinds of things that they need to
extract from this you know page
in addition
you may have images here in the pdf so
you need to extract that and analyze it
you may have tables and references
between tables so all together
you come to a point where you have
hundreds of operation for just you know
a single uh
page or single pdf and and their
articles can be comprises of thousands
of pages and they have many many
customers and they have many pdfs that
are coming in so you can think about the
um
how problematic it is
so
the approach that we took is basically
to run it as a serverless online
serverless serving so instead of running
it as a batch operation that will take
you know forever and won't be you know
efficient in terms of research resource
management the idea is to implement a
serverless framework that knows how to
read all those events and one of the
and let's you know talk about the
advantages of this architecture
first and foremost the fact that you can
use the same development
effort and the same development
architecture both in the development
environment and the production so when
you think about serverless and you focus
on your code it makes it really easy to
take that code and convert it into
production so that's a very very you
know key point here in this
architecture another thing is you need
to be able to support all kinds of
hardware in this online serving layer it
could be gpu it could be
servers with lots of uh you know uh
resources in terms of cpu and memory so
it could be cpu bound memory bounds
uh you need to make sure that you don't
have cold start so you're not waiting i
don't know 10 minutes to uh to do a cold
start
using cash for example to optimize the
performance and at the end of the day
you need to make sure that you can deal
with very complex pipeline that
comprises of many many steps
now in a very high level i mean when you
think about nlp in a very abstract way
it only has those you know parts so
you're getting the uh the pdf you do
some parsing you need to extract the
text and the images and all that kind of
stuff and then you may you know take it
to into vectors and name the eight
entities at the end of the day around
the similarity and uh generate an output
so it sounds you know pretty simple
but the reality is that you know it
looks like that this is their you know
actual graph and by the way we have a
webinar that we've done with the
customer so if you if you want to go and
take a look at it it's in iguazio
youtube you can see the customer talking
about all that
elements here so they have tons of
things tons of operations that they need
to do each and every one of them is is
basically a python function that is
running in this you know serverless
architecture
and those purple here represents
functions that need
processing of gpu for example the green
needs
more memory bound and then
in some cases you have some hotspot
and when you have hotspot you need to
make sure that you can scale up scale
down
leverage the resources in in a more
optimized way so you can imagine that
this graph is very very com complement
complex to to build basically you have
lots of operation you have lots of
requirements in terms of hardware you
need the ability to scale up and scale
down based on the workload lots of
things that you need to take under
consideration when you build such a
solution
so what is the solution solution
comprises of two elements one is an
orchestration layer something that is
called mr1 it's an open source uh that
we are driving and this is an
orchestration layer that basically
allows you to create graph to control
the resources so you can essentially
create all kinds of small function and
control resources like you know gpu
number of replicas
priorities node selectors all that kind
of stuff and it also has the ability to
you know
stitch together the different elements
and also provides you the ability to do
experiment striking so everything that
you're doing is being tracked so you can
see exactly what the functions are doing
with all the parameters results and so
on and so forth
and the second element is
something that is called nucleo it's a
serverless function it's like you know
amazon lambda function but with you know
steroid it can do hundreds of uh
thousands of events per second
and this is basically the engine for
doing the serving
so we're getting the data from a
streaming engine like kafka so we have
this ability to basically connect this
you know a function the serverless
function to any kinds of source so in
this case it's streaming source we have
a function that has in a couple of steps
then another element that we're using is
queuing so we have internal queue for
very very fast processing and retrieval
so this function basically writes down
into a queue then we have two other
functions one of them can use you know
gpu another one can use another
resources they're listening to the same
queue doing all kinds of processing
writing it to another queue and then it
goes on and on and on so obviously this
is a very very you know abstract way of
uh
depicting this solution but you get the
idea i mean you have an orchestration
layer you have a serverless function you
can scale up you can scale down you can
use all kinds of queuing in order to you
know basically communicate between the
different steps and eventually you're
running your code as small functions
running on top of kubernetes as a you
know containers
so
so just kind of you know to uh um to
give the highlights of you know the
benefits of you know this type of
solution so the nlp pipeline as i
mentioned earlier it requires lots of
you know operations so you need to to
build a graph that actually has the
ability to connect all kinds of you know
steps and one all kinds of operation the
pipeline could be very complex so you
need the ability to create a complex
graph with you know many many functions
um the cost is very important here
because you may say that okay let's take
a very very large cluster and and done
with it but nobody wants to do that you
want to make sure that you're cost
effective you know uh you know how to
react to different you know workloads
and scale up and scale down based on the
workload so the ability to take this you
know serverless approach allows you to
actually uh work against your workload
in a very very efficient way you know
auto scaling is very important and
another thing is once you free up the
resources especially when it comes to
gpu then you need to be able to share
those resources with others so if i have
a function that you know utilize the gpu
now it's done you want to share it with
another function
and going forward and basically free up
the resources so those are the the
elements that basically helps us to
come up with the architecture for s p
global
another case is from a small company
called the samsung
uh we've been working with the credit
card division they are doing real time
base location basic uh recommendation
they have 10 million some customers you
know ten thousands of data points
lots and lots of features and what they
wanted to do is basically to send
discounts and incentives to their users
that are hanging around in in south
korea and to do that based on their
profile and based on their location in
real time they've developed a neural
network uh
model that is running obviously on top
of gpus and they have thousands of
recommendations per second so it's it's
really you know a robust uh
solution that needs to
you know be tailored here in order to
address the requirements so we can see
how it looks like for the end users for
so for those that know how to read
korean you may know what it means but i
have no idea
and the the pipeline you know looks like
that so you have all kinds of different
sources you have transactions you have
the database you have third-party
information like you know weather so
it's really impactive you know it's cold
or hot outside so you have all kinds of
you know different parameters
all that you know data goes into a
staging area from that they're doing the
feature engineering that i mentioned
earlier with you know the feature store
so they can actually calculate you know
take the raw data calculate features
create in their case it's a kind of you
know vector that goes into a very fast
key value database that's another
important element within the solution if
you want fast retrieval you need to
store the data into a very fast key
value database so the feature store the
online feature store basically works
with a an online key value database that
is extremely fast for a quick writing
and quick
fetching of the data
then you have xgboss to basically you
know train the model and run it run it
on top of the uh the features and at the
end of the day you're doing the the
model serving and that goes to the
application so when the application in
your mobile sending the uad
then it goes here to the feature store
in which the data with the feature
vector and brings you know back the
result based on the the model result
so this is for uh samsung and last but
not least ecolab ecolab is a pretty big
company in the states that
are running operation around food and
health care for 170 countries what they
wanted to do this is a more generic
solution they basically wanted to create
what we call the machine learning
factory
to to build all kinds of uh
automation for their model deployment so
it's not just about a specific use case
they want to build a an environment and
framework that they can leverage for you
know many use cases
and the way it looks like is is the
following and this is kind of you know
uh the typical scenario where you have a
development environment using git for
the code then you're creating your
branch and then uh in your local
environment in your notebook you can
play around and you know create the
features do all the testing and and the
cool thing about it is that you can
actually take the data and convert it or
easily convert it into this serverless
function and even in your development
environment you can actually test it out
and see that things are actually running
properly and if so it goes into these
flow with
pull requests review tests and all that
kind of stuff the end of the day it goes
to the master and then you do the
deployment in production so this is how
their automation looks like but the the
most important thing here is that the
development environment for the user for
the data scientist is very similar to
the production environment you don't
need to change much you're taking the
same code and with some you know small
amount of code that wraps it you can
actually uh deploy it into production
and this is how they implement this you
know theory we don't need to go into
that detail but you know you get the
idea
so
kind of you know to summarize uh if you
want a good envelopes operation if you
really need to create what we call the
machine learning factory those are the
things that we believe that you need you
need to streamline the uh development
work in a way that it can work the same
way in your development environment and
production
using a serverless approach and a common
sdk and that's important you're getting
a common sdk to create
the code the same sdk is going to use in
production
this enables you basically to bridge the
gap between the data scientists and the
data engineers that in many cases are
working in silos using different
frameworks and stuff like that so
basically this idea streamline this
operation
and obviously the ability to create all
kinds of complex pipeline the pipelines
could be more batch oriented using
kubeflow or it could be more like you
know online pipeline using what i showed
you earlier like you know online
pipeline that is based on graph it's a
it's a different you know technology and
last but not least we didn't really talk
about that but there are all kinds of
things around governance and
auditability and things like that that
obviously you need to take care when you
build this machine learning pipeline
so
that's it any questions
yeah what are the main numbers the
python libraries that
you use in the system yeah so it's an
open environment i mean you can do
people install you can install whatever
you want and it comes with built-in
images that have all the popular stuff
you know tensorflow xc boost
scikit-learn whatever but it's an open
framework so you can just you know pick
and choose whatever you want to work
with there's no limitation
i think there's one over there
yes
what are the
[Music]
pregnant parameters
developer uh
procedure while
for writing automatically
[Music]
okay so i think the nice you know thing
about this architecture is that you
don't need to change anything in the way
that you're writing your
code yeah we're giving a platform and
you prov you're getting an sdk
yes so there is a wrapper that is called
ml1 that basically takes your code and
wrap it into a serverless under the hood
it creates a container that can run in
kubernetes cluster and it also does the
the auto login so it locks basically all
the you know the models and the
artifacts and everything into an
experiment tracking database so the
other technical things though but they
generalize generalize from like if you
are somebody
so so again there's no we're not
changing the way you create your model i
mean you can still create the model in
in the way that you used to you know
using python or whatever
you don't need to uh change anything
with you know creating your model what
we are delivering is basically a wrapper
that helps you to take that code and you
know deploy that in production then at
the end of the day the guys that are
responsible for production they need to
take care to set up the resources right
to make sure that uh you are bound into
specific resources whether it's you know
gpu whether it's a specific you know
memory or cpu limitation so they have
all kinds of you know uh consideration
that they need to take in place the
platform provides them a very easy way
to play around with it
[Music]
yeah it's a a
very friendly easy to use platform and
the idea is that it's kind of you know
stitch together all those elements and
provide you things like you know feature
store as i mentioned earlier
a gruffle you know doing the serving
pipeline
built-in model monitoring
there are many you know other aspects
but maybe we can take it offline
if you want to elaborate
so
you showed
three fairly big companies and you're
helping them with some processes
how does it look like for a company
coming to you like how do you like
approach them what do you do inside
eventually it's software but you do many
many other things other than software so
can you describe the process
yeah so basically it's a product so it's
pure we're a pure software company one
of the services company we sell the
product and by the way we can be
deployed anywhere on-prem and in the
cloud we support all the you know clouds
vendors
and the way it works is that customers
are describing the use cases usually and
then we help them to to build you know
the first or the you know second
pipeline so we have a customer success
team that you know basically guides you
how to do it on top of the platform but
from there the idea is that you can do
it on your own i mean you don't need us
in order to train your model and do the
deployment all that kind of stuff
developing the model is is obviously the
responsibility of the customer we are
helping them to actually follow the best
practice on how to leverage the platform
in the best way so they can come up with
uh what we call a machine learning
factory
you combine
consultation with software that you
provide yeah but but the main business
is product i mean
we do provide you obviously uh you know
some some sort of service in in the
first few days but the idea is not to be
a service company the idea is to you
know sell you the product and then
you're good to go we just had a very uh
a nice uh you know case recently with a
customer called the latam they wanted to
implement hundreds of models in in few
weeks without iguazi i think it would
have taken them like you know one year
or something like that so the idea is to
help them to create the environment and
the framework
so they can add more and more you know
models at a higher frequency at the end
of the day create more business services
and help their business in a better way
but you don't provide like the the
feature uh
the
feature analyzer i forgot to do future
stuff no
yeah yeah yeah we provide a feature
store we provide the features
and stuff like this no no no not off the
shelf models we provide a feature store
which is basically an infrastructure to
running the features and all that kind
of stuff we provide you the ability to
run the training using different
frameworks like in a desk hover and even
you know spark if you want we provide
you the ability to to have a built-in
model monitoring and connect the model
monitor to the feature store so we can
identify drift monitor the the model in
production
and we provide you this you know serving
layer that i mentioned earlier which
allows you to actually create the graph
that comprises of different functions
and and basically create a very more
complex you know serving like the the
nlp one that they showed earlier and
many many other stuff but uh you know we
can take it offline i guess thank you
but probably last question i guess
do you what database do you use for the
future
yeah it's a bad question because i don't
have a good answer
we're using our own currently we're
using our own database i mean we've
created a very very fast key value
database
so we're using that
the plan is to expand it and basically
support other databases like you know
radius and and other stuff but uh
does it uh support uh okay
yeah yeah you can install it in the
multi-region uh
all right thanks
[Applause]